Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy Mr
Speaker I guess one other issue you can
add is the origins of covid-19 the power
of subpoena is is one of the biggest
biggest most important things that
Republicans have gained with their
majority
that's true and Sean you've got to
realize why is a lot of this coming
forward you have some of the superstars
on this show from Rand Paul and you've
got to give a lot of shout out to Tom
Cotton for him going out forward but
remember for two years in the Democrat
majority they never had one hearing on
the origins of covet we promised it in
the commitment to America we have the
select committee on covid and what's
coming forward now is a lot of the
information that they know we're going
to get they know that we're moving
forward we promise to look after what
happened in Afghanistan why did we give
13 new gold star families we look why do
we have an attorney general going after
parents simply because they want to go
to a school board meeting all of this is
going to come truthful and there's a
pattern of behavior here denying the New
York Post story about Hunter Biden's
laptop denying about covid I remember
being in the Situation Room when
President Trump was in and Dr fauci
telling all this that the first origins
of hearing about covet in China that it
did not come come from China that it
could not come from that lab that it was
probably the market and also to tell us
we should not wear masks and then he
flipped about the mass afterwards all
those informations he wanted to very
first come out with that it could not
come from the lab in China at the very
beginning when he had no information it
makes you really wonder why he would
bring that at the very beginning these
house committee hearings are going to be
very very important it's important we
get to the bottom of it and get to the
truth of the American people and how
they've been so wrong on all this let me
ask you a question I've asked before it
looks like the deadline is somewhere
around June as it relates to the debt
ceiling Democrats seem to be calculating
that Republicans in the house will not
unite behind a single plan and they will
lose any leverage in negotiating raising
the debt ceiling are you confident that
your majority will unite behind one plan
probably including fiscal responsibility
well Sean we have to have fiscal
responsibility you saw what the
Congressional budget office just came
out with in the next 10 years we will
spend 10 trillion dollars just on
interest that will be our largest
payment today we have just gave China 60
million dollars we'll give them another
60 million tomorrow and the day after
wouldn't you rather have savings and
keep that money in America instead of
paying China on their interest after
what they did to covet and everything
else and it's not just Republicans are
going to stay United I've had
conversations with Democrats who've
quietly come to me and said Kevin you
are right we have to do something on
this debt limit we cannot continue the
path we're running down and you watch
the president he's going to have a
budget out I don't think anybody's going
to support his budget but we're going to
bring the CBO director in and I'm going
to have a bipartisan briefing just like
we do in the classified when we have a
top secret and a problem sitting out in
the world we're going to have this next
week with Republicans and Democrats
because the debt is that big of problem
that we're going to sit in the
auditorium we're going to listen to the
Congressional budget office and we're
going to start that conversation on how
do we turn the tide for the Next
Generation let's see if they actually
show up because they didn't show up at
the border when uh Jim Jordan had a
hearing last week by the way it was very
respectful uh Mr Speaker that you didn't
tear up Joe Biden's speech at the State
of the Union I got to give you a lot of
props for that all right thank you
speaker McCarthy we appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else